i was bringing back my brian loftus
traffic days
try trying to do all the best i can hey
zamboni off
and now the kids and the adults are back
on the ice look at that
bit of a breeze out there like we talked
about so if it's chilly outside
right now it's going to be even cooler
once we get to the evening
when you add the wind on top of that so
it's definitely some jacket weather for
tonight so
how many days without rain well 217 days
can you believe it
today of course nothing even with all
those clowns we knew that was going to
happen for the month
nothing okay this is where we should be
already
for october or i should say november we
should be just over a quarter of an inch
not even seeing that at all
so a lot of catching up to do we're
hoping december we'll get more storms to
come in
and give us some of that beneficial
rainfall to wrap up wrap up the year
it's just been a dismal year for rain 60
degrees for centennial hills right now
summerlin 58 56 for aliante
the east side coming in 60 even for
sunrise mountain green valley and also
henderson at 58 to 57 degrees whitney
ranch included two
seven hills 58 rhodes ranch and
mountains edge at 61. outside of town 57
for you and trump
love watching you guys out here sending
me emails out there from trump
54 for boulder city 61 laughlin and 68
out there in death valley all right
let's get to the satellite and radar
composite that's both of it combined
system tracking to the north bringing
the precip the shower activity along
with it unfortunately we didn't get any
of that
once that front slid through though we
did see the skies
clear up now we are watching this one
pinwheeling south
of alaska and this one is going to dive
down and what it's going to do is yes
temperatures will drop just a little bit
not a huge temperature drop but we will
see stronger winds and that will be
specifically on thanksgiving 35 mile per
hour gusts
30 for friday and then those winds will
die down relax a little more as we head
into the weekend so those will be the
big wind days
some elevated winds for tomorrow but
gusty winds on thursday i would be
surprised if we see some gusts up to 40
in some locales
on on thanksgiving night temperature
trend shows those numbers dropping
like we said thursday and friday ending
up again in mild above average by sunday
and monday here's your virtual forecast
again we want to show you what the
temperatures are going to be like for
tomorrow 52 degrees at 8 a.m
61 at lunchtime and 61 also
in the afternoon at about 4 p.m
seven-day forecast shows temperatures
near average through thursday or
wednesday i should say and then there's
those breezy winds on thanksgiving
and then like we said not a bad weekend
again brian over to you